(Gary claps)
(Swish claps)
(Gary and Swish laugh)
- [Swish] How are you today?
- I'm well. How are you?
- [Swish] I'm doing well,
I'm doing well.
- What can I help you with, man?
- I had a couple of questions.
I came prepared for.
- Okay.
- And I just wanted to ask you.
- [Gary] Sure.
- I'm from Canada and so I'm
in Toronto right now studying
university so first question,
very quickly is honestly
there's some day where I feel as
if I have working at a very high
level, I'm doing things, awesome.
But then there are other days
when you wake up and you know
those days where you
just don't feel like working.
- [Gary] Sure.
- Normally, it's like
those days which I have--
- [Gary] How often
are those days happening?
- Honestly,
twice a week sometimes.
It's just 'cause
school and other stuff.
- [Gary] It just
means, whatever,
one man's point of view,
and this takes away a lot of
psychological things
that I could never audit.
Like real depression,
things of that nature.
Like just even vibe I don't
think that's were dealing with,
it just means you're not doing
the thing you love the most.
- Right. It could be.
- [Gary] I believe
that to be true.
- Right. Mhmmm.
I mean, normally--
- I feel like
that's a class example of
somebody who's motivated--
- [Swish] Right.
- and is like generally happy
and wants to make that happen--
- [Swish] Sure.
- but is just not doing
what they want to be doing.
- [Swish] Cool. Okay.
- The only time I get into that
pattern is when I'm not doing
what I want to be doing.
That pattern hasn't
really existed since
I got out of school.
- [Swish] Right.
- You know?
- [Swish] Yeah.
Yeah and how
did you find school?
- The worst. I was
a terrible student.
I punted it.
I thought it was not for me.
- [Swish] Right.
- And not in a disrespectful,
like you know it's great when
I say it now because people
know I went on to be successful.
- [Swish] Right.
- And so I was being fair.
I wasn't like a
loser who's like,
"Ah, school," and I just
wanted to do more loser things.
- [Swish] Right.
- I was like, "Damn it,
this is not built for me."
- [Swish] Mhmmm.
- Like, I don't give a shit
about "The Catcher in the Rye."
- [Swish] Yeah.
- Like, the symbols
for fucking salt are going
to do me no good, you know?
(Swish laughs)
But like, but if they
like if they God forbid,
it's funny, history
I did well because I thought
I saw patterns,
it's how I did business.
- [Swish] Right.
- History tells you the future.
It's why I'm good
at predicting stuff.
- [Swish] Sure.
- It's, you know,
it's pattern recognition.
- [Swish] Right.
- That was cool.
- [Swish] Mhmmm.
- Hey, don't let these
things happen because
that's how wars start.
Hey, don't let
these things happen,
that's how like you know
suppression of
information can happen.
Like that was good.
- [Swish] Correct.
- But like other things that I
knew weren't gonna be me so
I struggled with it but
I struggled with it in hindsight
by being respectful to it.
Knowing it worked for others.
- [Swish] Right.
- School's not
stupid for everybody.
- [Swish] Mhmmm.
- School was stupid for me.
- [Swish] Okay.
- So that's how
I dealt with it.
- [Swish] And you knew
that from an early age, right?
- I knew that
from a very early age.
I'm self-aware
for the most part, right?
- [Swish] Right.
- And have grown into
it obviously but yeah,
I knew at a fairly young age.
- [Swish] And when you
talk about self-awareness,
that's another thing too is
I've heard you talk about that.
I read your book.
Loved it and I think one thing
though is it's hard to teach
self-awareness to
someone, right?
- [Gary] Yes.
- It really is hard.
So for people who aren't--
- [Gary] I think, yeah, I think
the thing that I'm trying to
accomplish is I'm trying
to just make it a conversation.
- [Swish] Right.
- I don't think I'm gonna solve
self-awareness but I'd sure love
to be a little tiny
sliver in all the people,
if I can talk about it so much
that it becomes a cool thing to
talk about as 25-year-old
businessmen and women and one of
them goes on to do, you know?
- [Swish] Right.
- I like to be part of it
because boy is it the game.
- [Swish] Yeah. Definitely.
I mean my mom, I don't know.
My mom also tends to
believe in that type of thing.
She doesn't call it
self-awareness we had
a Hindi term for it. (laughs)
- What was it called?
- [Swish] Utvasha.
- Utvhasa.
- [Swish] Utvasha, yeah.
- Like how do
you translate it?
- [Swish] It just
means knowing yourself.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Swish] You know?
- [Gary] She's right.
You're lucky.
If you're lucky enough to have
a mom that believes in that,
no wonder you
got to this moment.
- Thank you for that.
She'll be very happy with that.
(Swish and Gary laugh)
So I'm also, I consider myself
to be not a
conventional entrepreneur.
That idea, like you are, I'm
more of a social entrepreneur.
(inaudible) I think at least I'm
trying to help that (inaudible).
Honestly, money is
something that is high,
I want it.
- [Gary] Sure.
- But I don't see
it as my end goal.
- [Gary] Sure.
- I really do think helping
people in the number one way,
and of course helping
people like you do is a
way you get to money, right?
It just works out for you.
- [Gary] There's so many
ways to do the right thing.
- [Swish] Sure.
- And the selfish thing and
there's a lot of
different patterns.
Some spend 50 years of their
life being unbelievably selfish
and then then deploy
unbelievable generosity.
- [Swish] Right.
- You know, my big
thing is the content. Right?
Like I have entrepreneur
friends who buy an umbrella,
give an umbrella or one
$0.10 out of everything and
I debate with them, social
entrepreneurs who are my homies.
- [Swish] Right.
- First of all, 80% of
them are using good as
a disguise for their truth.
- [Swish] Yes.
- Let's call a spade a spade.
The 20% that I'm able to
sniff out that are legit,
we have amazingly deep
conversations 'cause I'm like
look cool, my autobiography is
called "The Honey Empire"
in my own head.
I think I'm gonna build an
enormous success and I think I'm
gonna do it the
best way possible.
I think this thing that somebody
just sent me is very true to me
which is I don't care about
how much money is
in my bank account.
I do care about how many, why
the fuck am I meeting with you?
- [Swish] That's true.
- I need this
five minutes, my man.
But to be very frank with you,
I need this five minutes.
- [Swish] Mhmmm.
- I'm doing it because
intuitively it feels like,
it felt like the right
thing to do based on the email.
I don't know.
It's very random.
- [Swish] Right.
- And so, I think there's
a lot of ways to do good.
Just think there's a lot of ways
to do good and I think that the
thing to find out is I think
too many young entrepreneurs
who think they're doing good,
don't realize the
money's not the part.
- [Swish] No.
- It's not the part.
Do you know how much easier it
is for me to sign $100,000 check
to a charity now than it is to
be on the board of a charity?
I need my time.
- [Swish] Right.
- So I have all
these homies who are like,
"Yes, but I give
a percentage back."
I'm like, "The
money's the easy part.
- [Swish] Right.
- How about bringing
value to the ecosystem?
- [Swish] Right.
- How about putting in the work?
- And so, I, the most confusing
thing I do in public is I leave
a lot of money on the
table by being GaryVee.
There's people watching this
right now think they way I built
my personal brand is why I have
this wealth because they don't
understand that I actually built
a business long before I was
anybody and if I spent every
hour and every piece of energy
on actually just
building businesses like the one
you're in right now,--
- [Swish] Right.
- I'd have more money not less.
But what I do with this is kids
in Toronto can watch it and use
it to build their future.
- [Swish] Literally.
- Literally.
- [Swish] Literally, yep.
- [Gary] Literally.
- And honestly, that's why I
reached out to you. (inaudible)
I applied to be a project
manager here at your company
last year and then I was
like maybe I should probably
internship for a while.
I got the (inaudible)
but I was dead set on here.
- [Gary] I love it.
- I really want to work here.
- [Gary] I love it, man.
Well, listen, real pleasure.
- As well. Real pleasure.
- I'm sure we'll get
to see each other again.
- Definitely. Thank you.
- Yeah, man, good luck to you.
- Do you mind if
I take a quick--
- Let's do it.
- Okay, great.
- No worries.
- This is for my mom. (laughs)
- Let's do a selfie.
- A selfie.
Okay, awesome.
- Let's get some of
the view, I got--
- You do have a beautiful view.
- Awesome.
- I appreciate it.
- My man, good luck to you.
- [Swish] I really
appreciate it. Thank you.
- Love your vibe.
- Thank you so much.
- [Gary] Yes?